hi good evening everyone
welcome to the langley law title
navigating the pandemic your korean
design
it is precisely during this challenging
times that we need to
step up and improve ourselves to stay
relevant and to seize opportunities
whether you're a design student or
professional in design thank you
for joining us this evening i'm eugene
from the design singapore council
and i'll be introducing the program for
this seasoning
this evening this event is organized by
the design singapore council
in partnership with skills future
singapore and supported by the national
design center
this event is also part of the national
design center's program lineup for
october
where you focus on young talents in the
design sector
so today's session explores navigating
your career in design throughout the
pandemic
and this is the program for this evening
we are honored to have with us leaders
from the industry to share their career
journeys
and to participate in today's panel
discussion
but before we start this evening session
i'd like to pass the time over to my
colleague julie to share more about the
design symbol council
and what we do at the talent development
team over to you shilli
thanks eugene hi everyone i'm silly from
the talent development division at dsg
and i'll be sharing with you on two
funding schemes which my team
administers
to support aspiring designers design
practitioners
and design advocates in their
professional development journey
so first up is the design singapore
scholarship which supports
formal education and design to groom
design leaders who strive to make things
better by design
and contribute to singapore and the
design sector
applicants must be a singapore citizen
or permanent resident
have completed national service for male
applicants and have gained
admission to a full-time undergraduate
or postgraduate design related course
meaning bachelor's master's or phd that
are offered locally or overseas by a
reputable
institution the next application
cycle is in february to april 2021
under the scholarship there is a
holistic development framework put in
place for our scholars
in terms of financial coverage it will
be in these five areas
namely full tuition fees travel
allowance to cover airfare to and fro
the country of studies
pre-study allowance for settling in
computer and warm clothing
developmental cost allowance for
self-development programs outside of
school
and leaving allowance to cover living
expenses in the country of study
for our scholars development journey we
will assign a body from the design
singapore associates network
which is the network for all dsg
scholars whether they have graduated or
are still studying
and they can come together to
collaborate exchange
ideas and organize events for both the
design community
and the community at large next there is
also a compulsory one-month internship
to be served in singapore during the
course of studies
for application of knowledge and
on-the-job experience
on top of these dsg will also facilitate
other mentorship and job matching
opportunities
as for the bond to be served it should
be a full-time design related role in a
singapore registered company
whether it is an sme mnc with a
singapore base
or setting up your own studio the bomb
period depends on the country of study
and the duration of the course
next we have the skills future study
award for design
it is a 5 000 monetary award with no
bond
for early to mid careers singaporeans
looking to deepen technical skill sets
or to
develop complementary skills it can be
for both designers
and non-designers with at least three
years of working experience
who are seeking to either take on
dedicated design roles in in-house
design
or innovation teams or advocate for
design adoption in their current
organizations
or skill or accelerate a design
entrepreneur's business
the final application cycle in financial
year 2020
is opening in a week's time on 26
october 2020
and will close on 15 january 2021
so we hope that you can keep the two
funding schemes in mind as you go
through today's webinar
in the meantime if you have any
questions on the resources shed
please feel free to ask them via the q a
module and we will do our best to answer
all your queries
so without further ado i'm proud to
introduce our moderator and speakers for
today
for moderator we have miss priest mock
on board she is the deputy chief
executive from rohit corporation
as for the speakers we have mr truett
wanwan tanasu
chief designer chief design officer and
managing director
dbs bank mr jeff chung
president of tribal worldwide asia and
deputy ceo of ddb group singapore
and last but not least mr ryan han
assistant director
and design practitioner from wildlife
reserve singapore
so now i'll hand the time over to praise
hello there good evening and welcome
um it's great to be here and i am just
thrilled to be able to be in in the
company of
very creative people so um my name is
praise and i'm with rohit which is a
learning and consulting organization
we've been here 13 years now and we're
locally set up
and we specialize in learning and
consulting
and we've been working with
organizations and individuals in a space
of
change leadership and also culture
building
right so my interaction with design has
been in the crafting
of learning experiences we do have those
that
are both face to face and remote we've
done over 60 of them right now
and we've trained over 70 000 learners
uh and my job today
is to create a space for our speakers uh
true aide jeff and ryan
to be able to share from their
experience uh and
hear how the design profession is
currently evolving
and also to share some of their tips and
insights on what you can be doing right
now to be able to
help yourself find a a great space
in this profession and in this industry
okay so i'm just going to leave it with
uh true egg to introduce yourself
hello everyone so my name is chuwick so
i
have been working in singapore for
almost 10
years now i'm moving actually from us to
camo to set up this design team
and now i've set up a design team in dbs
it has been about
seven years so we actually grew the team
from two to seven
and we have a lot of discipline in the
team and i'm happy to be here to
give you some insights or maybe some
tips that you can be useful for you in
the future
thank you thank you i think jeff you
wanna
say hi jeff hi everybody um thanks for
having us before your dinner uh we
promised to make this uh
as advertising uh as possible so that
you know we
it won't be a drag um my name is jeff uh
i actually
uh graduated from thomas polytechnic
back in
1996 right in graphic design so i
started my career as
a graphic designer um doing all sorts of
logo branding
and i've kind of gone a full cycle to
advertising technology was involved in
some startups
and today i am very privileged uh to be
tasked
with the responsibility to lead uh one
of uh singapore's
hottest creative agency at ddb group
singapore
some of my colleagues are here want a
big shout out to them so tonight we hope
to
uh have a like what praise say to have a
very safe space for us to share some
tips
uh that you can actually apply tomorrow
so uh we've met
all the the speakers uh and we guarantee
you a good show tonight
great thanks jeff ryan you want to go
ahead and introduce yourself
hey hi everyone uh so good evening so
uh really glad to be here so a big
background for myself
uh graduated in nyp industrial design
subsequently i started my career as an
industrial designer
so consumer electronics products so i've
been to creative technology then i shift
my career
uh kind of a bit to teaching then
subsequently at sync health so more
healthcare
and subsequently at dbs finance then now
i'm at wrs
so it's uh it's a very different
industry
from one another but still applying the
same context of you know design
and you know empathy and all those
ideations and stuff like that so
uh i'll we i think we will be sharing
more about all
all this uh in a while yeah
great thanks ryan so i'm just gonna jump
in and uh
looking forward to to what these three
gentlemen have to share i think thank
you dsg for
being able to curate such a skilled and
experienced pool
um first question i think i'll just
throw it out to
to us our team here would be how
actually has
covet and economy impacted um the design
projects that you've embarked on maybe
you can share a little bit to provide
some context of
you know about the current time
okay so i can go first i mean the code
actually hit
us in a different way right but the way
to impact the project it actually is
something that
uh we quite uh like the way it hit us
because it actually make us to
understanding what are the
the last mile something that we're
missing during the project
because a lot of time when things go
well we have a back up right like
if things not go wrong could go go well
then you can call call center you can go
to the brand but now the brand has been
closed down
because everybody deviates so that the
context will be more the banker then
financially like all the money is really
important so we can't fill the system
so no matter what happened we need to
make it work so a lot of project that
coming in we call
it called the urgent project but we have
to really deliver like
something that you guys might not know
but we have a lot of a
dormitory for the worker in singapore
and most of the time when they lock down
majority of them in the dormitory and
they cannot send the money out to their
relative or the family overseas
so and most of the time they don't they
don't use
those online banking they normally go to
certain place right to
do remittance now they're forced to do
it and then
at the beginning we thought onboarding
were easy like we know we can read the
screen but
for them very different they don't have
confidence to send the money that they
earn
to some on on screen and they're not
sure that the money will reach there
so a lot of things are coming up and we
need to actually adapt and
try to push the project out in very
short time frame some project we used to
do six months
you have to do in one month so those are
the things actually impact us but i
think this is a good learning for us
and a lot of blind spot that we have
been
kind of neglected and maybe we don't
think about it that much actually
surfacing up
so i think that's uh that's a good
learning for us
great thanks joey a lot i think a lot of
compression of time
right six to one is is incredible i
think we're hearing a lot of that as
well
um jeff ryan anything to share around
this
okay i can share so uh in wrs because uh
as all of y'all know we are doing uh
we do have this expansion plan so the
monday presents
so that itself is still we'll still
continue
uh with the new park moving in but of
course there might be some delay la so
uh there's one but i think the current
uh of course as you all know the tourism
has been
impacted uh but uh what we are doing is
that
i think you have heard about sdb uh they
are trying to
uh channel all those local uh locals to
to visit or revisit our parks or our
the the whole tourism line in a sense so
so i think it's
it is it's it's okay so but what i think
is that during kobe we have to be
adaptable because
uh government is slowly opening up so we
have to
be adaptable to all this you know
changes
or or things like that yeah so so
it might impact a bit but but uh we are
we are still
trying to to be adaptable in all these
changes like
but yeah so so they say but project wise
they are still still
ongoing yep thanks ryan adaptability is
key
in in this time all right um jeff
anything to share
since uh ryan shared about adaptability
i'll talk about agility
uh the two things um that i've learned
and still learning from kobe our
interaction with kobe was on the second
day of the lunar new year
i've got a call back i terminated my
visiting and went back to office uh we
were asked
uh by one of the client uh to actually
who's actually responsible for
the whatsapp group that you guys
received every day
from the government on the covet status
so
back in back in the earlier days we were
tasked to design
this system where it could actually
deliver timely
information on the the covet situation
to citizens to sign up uh it was
actually quite um
quite a tour order because uh you know
it went through
uh several rounds of iterations uh and
then of course um
with um the uh coming in of golftec and
then
facebook community partners they all
came in um within
a couple of days uh the system was um
up and running and it was constantly
fine-tuning until until the the robust
level as it is today
so we're very glad to be involved in
such a project it's short turnaround
time
um i think the team was really involved
and and this
uh hardly slept uh i i i must thank the
team
um i i couldn't do anything because my
programming skills is not up to scratch
but i could only sit there to um
you know be a cheerleader the second
thing that they came up for us
uh based on agility was on the second
day of circuit breaker
uh we suddenly had a um
a new situation where we have to live
with that we've not lived in before
uh this social isolation and because
we're we are in the business of
um human connection we we we really love
to have brainstorm
to have coffee and it's now the human
interaction is gone and we just find
that we are just kind of been thrown
into a whole new world um and then
and then from the basic needs of what to
eat you know that question
came out uh and and then what we
actually did was we decided to pull
together all the resources and we i'm
not sure if it's in this website but we
created this website called um
it's not very clear here like i am a
ccd.com uh what it does it actually
pulls in
um the user generated content from
communities around singapore
from the best place for food from the
best place to get services and all that
um and then we provided a platform for
smes
who are new into the online business to
come on board to start trading to start
selling the stuff
without taking a cut uh from them and
this has been one of um one of the
things that we we kind of enjoy
it's like a public service um uh a
project that we did and of course the
the evolution of that allow us to focus
on mental wellness
uh where we think um we work with nuh
to provide um a self-help
uh kind of like diagnostic like like
diagnostic survey
where you can take um and to kind of
like have a benchmark on how well you're
scoring on
the mental wellness um so these are the
two things that
that that allowed us to use the agility
that we have learned
for over the years and apply it in the
shortest possible time to get
a project up and going great thank you
thank you gentlemen i i think one of the
things that is that
i'm picking up here is that there has
been a increased
num amount of collaboration right across
industry across uh
public private um what is your what is
your observation here
around that as a skill for individuals
who are
professions in design um this ability to
collaborate
disability to be able to connect and all
can you share a bit about
how that is showing up because i'm
picking it up and what you're sharing
the the kind of projects you're
undertaking
okay so i i think for the designer or in
the design field right most of the time
we have been
talking about the connected dot right we
are the one that connects most of the
dot and missing link and a lot of things
i think what what the crisis bring us is
actually something that
some organization may be maybe not know
how to the how the decide work or maybe
what the value decide bring to the table
this is something if you can grab
opportunity this is
the event that you can showcase a lot
something like uh
the easy part that you can see we draw
some customer journey sometime
that is really helping but what is
missing and see lots of video that we
actually producing nowadays because
once you have uh the video feed or lots
of things that we are coming from uh
on the ground and those are the things
that we are using quite a lot
and collaboration with organization that
not just our
customer itself but we also have to work
with government like mom
to fix the dominatory for the worker we
have to work with a lot of organization
mohs and lots of things so those
actually
having a to mapping the stakeholder and
try to connect the dot that each
organization needs certain data i do not
talk about data yet but
a lot of com like everyone looking for
some data right they need to
check the you know who get infected
those are the things mohs want to take
another data
and we want to make sure that you know
we were in the dormitory never
left the dominatory so we have a lot of
data that they're sharing with us
because we need to know who actually
have been sending the money out
who is not then actually we need to kill
that man because
when you build a system it not it take
let's say one month right
during that 30 day we need to make sure
that you know everybody have a chance to
send money out so a lot of things
have been collaborated i think that's
really helpful for us as
a as a design team right so
that that was a lot of interaction with
uh like uh
government agencies and also i think um
with the the amount of data and what you
had to do with it
yeah okay great um jeff ryan anything to
to add around um how
how the the um perceiving that the role
of the design
designer um someone in this profession
it needs to embrace a lot more
stakeholder management
can you share a little bit about that uh
i think for my side
because during coving all of us are
working from home last so of course
kind of thing we will be using teams and
stuff like that then uh of course we uh
we have been doing
quite a number of brainstorming you know
online so so i will not talk about the
ops
partner which you know all the things
but i think personally for you know
designers or
uh in our role in our job is to look at
look up for also potential kind of
a medium to help us to better facilitate
uh all this
uh you know brainstorming or ideations
or or stuff like that so
for example we even went to miro which i
think is a
good platform uh to to come together uh
uh to do to ideate uh to come up with
ideas to cluster
of the affinity clustering and and so
and so forth so
i think that gives us of for
personally i think it opens up my mind
in that
uh in the past we always use post-its
and
and now we have to change a bit uh to
use
all this to co to to of course
stakeholder management
and how to present ideas and and all
from from
online so so i think it's something that
uh true covet that has changed quite a
lot
yeah but of course personally i still
prefer the hands-on physical
you know workshops or facilitating
workshops
right thank you ryan so i think
understanding the different mediums the
new mediums that that are now
um part and parcel of life yeah
jeff well i think quite similar to what
ryan shared
um technology is uh our good friend
during circuit breaker we still had to
deliver our work
uh and uh it's i think we're lucky
because as a digital
company we we've already started to use
um all these collaboration tools and all
that i would never
imagine uh sitting in front of a
computer for more than 10 hours facing
the screen and just talking
so actually for the first three days of
circuit breaker we all had like sore
throat
but i guess one of the most challenging
stuff was for us to actually
execute um the the filming
in restricted amount of crew
over remote uh remote access that was uh
that was very tough because we had to
work with
live talent directors and all that but
i'm glad we did that i'm glad we did
that because uh from from that episode
we kind of learned that we can actually
uh be more productive uh but i agree
with ryan
nothing beats the real-life interaction
because you can feel and you can direct
so we look forward to i mean right now
um the the social distancing has um
has eased off a little bit but we're
still maintaining uh that distance
uh but it was a very good learning
experience because when we needed
certain
the live streaming technology a lot of
the the equipment that we use
uh weren't ready uh the the wi-fi was
patchy the data was patchy
uh and then you you kind of wonder like
you know what have you been paying or
you know all this well for all the data
it doesn't seem to be working as fast as
they claim
okay so guys we've been talking um quite
a bit around
the different attributes like agility
and
being able to be adaptable and also
being able to collaborate
are there other skills on the technical
side that you might want to share
with um with our listeners right now
of you with in terms of uh skills that
you're observing
are important at this particular time
okay skill set is a bit
i think we all use all the skills skill
set that we have but i think
multitasking starts to popping up more
and then you know how you actually
divide your time because
you know the one day i sit on my chair
like the first whole day
because the meeting normally you walk
right you have 15 minute walk and
other than people start to pack up your
meeting back to back
so you now you need to start to do how
you do multitasking
how you grab attention in the meeting
because you know sometimes people might
look at you by seeing they look at
something else
because you won't know that they
actually pay attention so
a lot of eye contact lots of uh
projection of the voice
how the voice come off like you can see
the from chip and ryan they their voices
have been two now because they have been
doing quite some time so now
they know what kind of tone that can
grab attention so that's as a skill
the new skill that the you know the
designer or someone that lead the
project when you present something
you need to make sure that you over a
kind of power of
all the distraction that the user might
have because otherwise it's very hard to
grab attention
in this time when you're on in the
meeting room it's very easy you can
look at the people and they can look at
the phone so much right but now
on this they can just grab the phone you
don't even know
so a lot of things that you need to
that's a new skill that we need to learn
yeah great that's great don't worry
we're all looking at you chewing we're
here we're present
right um guys ryan jeff any any
uh other skills that you're observing i
think to add on to trek's
part i think uh very relatable uh so uh
for example when we are doing uh like
facilitate or maybe we are sharing a
meeting
uh the problem now is that everybody is
using you know zoom or teams
and most actually they switch off the
videos
so you can't really see the the real
life uh time kind of interaction like so
a thing is that we have to do is to uh
ask them
that question so that i know they know
understand what i'm i'm saying like or
at least to get it
so so these are some new skills or or
things when
i think as a designer uh we have to do
now like in this
current situation because it's kind of
difficult to
to to people's attention uh
on teams or or zoom like correct
yep and of course oh sorry to add on
uh because in the past in the physical
world right in all in
in in in the physical we can use
whiteboard or at least as a designer i
like to use whiteboard to draw
so that people knows you know that i
have the same language or same
understanding
but now it's a bit difficult although
you know teams
might have the white board but it's
still a bit difficult
so these are the things that you know
before you present something you have to
make sure that
it's easy to understand and you can
guide your your stakeholders
along the way uh and and not to be so
confused
like it's basically because if you
compared to the physical world
it can be like that and can be done
easily through a whiteboard but in
digital world or it might be difficult
so so you have to plan and map out
before you start to present something
uh that's my thoughts yeah quite a bit
of planning beforehand
yeah trying to touch on maybe a little
bit on well-being
since the two gentlemen have talked
about the operations and work and the
technique to engage the clients
um i think because of the physical
disappearance uh from from the office
right it's it's
possibly quite hard to um
ascertain if your co-worker is feeling
well doing okay
is he overwhelmed uh with work so i
think
um while as leaders sometimes we we need
to
be there to to help to keep a lookout
but it's quite impossible for us to look
at everything
so so my my my thing is that like as
i've been speaking to all my leaders is
we need to really encourage the team
members
right to exercise self-care because um a
lot of them
are very driven and i was so blessed to
have such a good team
and sometimes they they can't detach
from
from work and then and there's no you
you can't get out
you know during the circuit breaker time
so it kind of forces the person to be
kind of like in prison
at home so um so i think that the
the at least for the various groups i
was in i mean i was pleasantly surprised
where
uh some some of the my colleagues
because they realized that i got
saltwater they
put together a care pack and they sent
los angeles over to me i actually
thought that someone
made a wrong delivery but i was
pleasantly surprised i think caring for
one another is very important
um because especially when you work in a
team when you care for one another you
you then can work together because
there's room for more collaboration and
if one team member is down you can't
move forward so i think self-care
is is key thanks jeff i think what
you're also alluding to is just that
care for others self-care and care for
others the compassion
right to be able to look out it's really
sweet of your team to send a care pack
along
and um and that actually is one of the
uh factors that has shown up recently in
terms of the
um in terms of the skills that people
are looking for the attributes and
scare it's just the ability to have the
you know the eyes that look outside and
look towards others as well so there's i
think i think um
you were sharing around multitasking and
ryan you were saying well it's really
important to plan
and jeff was talking about self-care um
would there be any
technical skills that you observe in
this uh in this new way of doing things
that are that one cannot fail but
but must uh must do you know because we
are
we i think a lot of our viewers may be
uh graduating into into the sector
right maybe just starting out some are
also coming potentially considering a
switch out into the sector so if if you
had some thoughts or a
roundup for them what tips would you
give in terms of okay guys if you're
gonna be in the space
you know there's some some skills that
you must have
as a designer to to be able to start off
well any thoughts around that
okay i think i can start first uh
i think i will not talk about i'll put
skills aside first but i think the first
thing
uh for me is more about mindset
as i think previously i mentioned about
that adaptability
um i think for new grads or even those
who wants to
who are thinking of changing to to this
line i think
uh that adaptability is
one key like because um things
moves really fast and if you talk about
my
uh in my past experience like i
graduated about 205
206 the thought back then was
to be just a industrial designer and not
other things and just work
that that that job or that role
but you know things move too fast that
uh you have to be
adaptable and move and shift according
to what
the trend is or you will be you know you
will not be
following the trend or your casa in a
sense so
so i think one uh that would be the
mindset part
uh and just think of it like design is
applicable to every single thing uh most
of the things are
so so it's all about applying that
design uh
thoughts or or or the framework into
every it can be applied into any
industry so
uh so so so it's it's it's
it's there so then the other one i think
the skill set uh for me i realized this
few years
uh the trend or even myself is that uh
designers
are not just purely designers only
they should have a skill set of being a
pm appropriate project manager this is
recently i just
few years i think that is a very
critical point to be
a bit like a hybrid so it's like a
designer pm hybrid kind of thing where
i think this will be the new kind of
designer unicorns in the future
because it's not about just designing
but also able to understand what the
business
needs and wants and help to resolve that
decision and of course
i think the critical role or why a lot
of companies are hiring designers is
that
a designer can actually help to bridge
the user part and
of course they can also help to convince
the stakeholders and also
looking at the whole end-to-end and
everything like so i think that's the
that's the skill set i i
suggest or advice like those who wants
to be in this in this uh
to be a designer to to have uh that
because that's why for c in the future
or even now
this is happening uh designer pm hybrid
kind of uh
trend yep that's a great tip
being adaptable and also acquiring the
skill of being able to project manage
so you can attend to business needs and
i think it was insightful for you to see
that
the the reason for hire is often also to
bridge to bridge the understanding of
needs
of the users to to to product
development et cetera
that's great thank you so much ryan um
what else what other tips do we what we
have uh
today so i think for for me like i
always
tell my team that actually if you look
into the design team or designer or
whether that you in the team with
creative team
your job is normally three things that
you normally do
the first one i'll show you why they
want to build design team because design
team can
make it tangible so we make business
leader vision
or the team vision to be tangible
because we can do prototyping we can do
a lot of things right that's part of
our skill that we have we can draw
things we can make things look
real and you can use it and taste it
second
we dare because we actually try to
understand user very hard
harder than other than so that's why the
skill that you need to have is
how you listen you deep listening how
you observe because sometimes
even though you're in the testing
customer might say something but they do
the other thing
we have seen that so often like we ask
them because we
give them incentive to come to the
testing lab right sometimes
they try to say certain things or
cultures are different like you go hong
kong tasting
taiwan tasting also very different so
you have to be able to understand the
customer really carefully and you don't
use it as a guide but
don't have to really like 100 customers
say this you need to deliver this
you need to send decide the information
that so and the last one
we elaborate technology so as ryan
mentioned that all the
tactical skills that you have you can
learn you have to learn very fast
because
last time i remember that the
dreamweaver or you know the illustrator
they never changed
i think one or two years they machine
one time now with every three months
like figma whatever they just reload
you know all the software you have to
really learn again so you have to learn
those technical skills very fast and
also understand
what technology can bring to the table
but try to not forfeiting technology
into the thing that you design so you
have to understand what it actually can
leverage and what cannot be done yeah so
that's about three things that i
emphasize for my team for the learning
and the growth
wow great so um make it tangible support
making things tangible because you can
you can make things happen you can make
things
be seen by drawing by making um
try to understand by listening and
observing what's really going on
yeah and i think the leverage of
technology right
so great thank you thank you
jeff okay so maybe maybe i start off
with um
an overview on the growth sectors and
design
so many of you who are attending this
talk are possibly
related to a design field of study uh in
all shapes and
and all formats um a post covet world
i'm very confident to say that we are
looking at a
um an industry that requires a lot of
designers why number one
there is a fundamental shift in how
consumers are
moving to to interact with uh products
services and brands and content right so
uh for example in the pharmaceutical
world you are
you you would have seen that there is a
rise in teleconsulting healthy
businesses
and uh you know that you can now talk to
a um
a medical profession uh online as
as we are doing right now and then the
consultation can be done
your medicine or your mc can be
delivered under three hours
right but uh having having gone through
a couple of it myself because i was
doing some research on it
none of the none of the tools or the
apps available out there
are actually you know as slick as uh
what i would expect uh uh uh
uh you know to have come off from
someone who actually done some user
experience
design on it so very nice an opportunity
for
all of us here are the designers who are
welders and user experience
uh to create the kind of interface to
bring the brand to bring the experience
closer to the consumer
um and and the other thing is the the
rise of e-commerce and the rise on
uh content you would have seen so many
people um
going to you know facebook live or
whatever platform
ig live to start selling their product
um
there is a combination of shopping and
entertainment coming together so we call
it shop attainment
someone needs to design the backdrop
someone's need to design the interface
someone's needs to
design the experience who's there to do
it if
no one rise up to the challenge and i
guess these are something that's
not entirely new so if you look at if
you look at
shopper um shoppertainment as i said
earlier on
it was actually for those of you who are
old enough okay
you may remember this thing called cello
vision where
people sell things over the television
and then you call to make your order
it's actually the same thing but it's
using a different medium right now
so when we are faced with all these
things all these new new products right
which was not in our playbook which was
not in our textbook
but what does it require us to do so i i
always say this to my team members
you must be very good in chaos
management
right chaos management is key and being
designers right somehow we have this
innate nature in
us um to be very methodical in our
thinking
uh and we are able to see things that um
you know to in
in in wireframes and and wired mapping
um
and that helps us and that's gonna set
you apart
uh from any of the the people who's
eyeing for the job
so i say um you must to it so if you
don't know what what is that you have to
go pick up a book and start reading what
is user experience
um and and to have this hunger for
continuous learning
i think learning um is is something that
is very important all the skills that
i've learned when
dot com first started it's like archive
3d
what should we say from dreamweaver i
still remember like
i still like figuring out dream river
and go live
at adobe go live in the past but then
now it's all gone so
um technology it's here today and gone
tomorrow so
um yeah so just recap three point
there's a demand in design right now
you must be very good in chaos
management and then you must continue to
have the hunger to learn
fantastic i think um ryan had mentioned
some uh earlier that actually
design is in is everywhere you could
pretty much
you know see the potential for design in
everything that we're doing
um so a question around
what has impressed you about those
wanting to join your team can you share
a little bit around that
i i'm sure many have have come knocking
at the door
wanting to have a chat with you etc so
what are some of the things that have
impressed you about those
that have been wanting to join your team
okay so i think for
i mean in interview we have been doing
in-person interview now we do virtual
interview
so most of the time that we in you know
we say okay this person actually we
should hide them actually mostly
attitude
and then you know the smile that they
have uh they have been
need to be super like optimistic i mean
during this time right so they
they see that you know attitude that
they bring uh how they present the work
virtually
nowaday and then you know how they
prepare you know they have one design
actually they
i mean he actually prepared the
presentation
then he need to make sure that the phone
actually big enough because
last time when you present in the
meeting you have a projector and
everything right now
with the screen actually not that big so
the font side they need to redo so
actually he actually thoughtful about
looking into those more detail
actually i quite like it and you know
they they
i mean he cut down all the video because
the wife will not carry over
during the i'm sure you have problem
that when you have embedded video
you might not the other side will not
hear it so those are the things that
they have been prepared
that show that how they adapt to the new
environment how they present the world
and also creativity of you know how they
actually showcase their work as well
so those are the things that are
actually quite impressive when we see
someone actually
you know coming into the um the
interview virtually
great thank you so create uh be
optimistic you know the energy
that you bring in um being present to
prepare like
the thoughtfulness around actually the
user experience right the font size
yeah uh and also creativity okay great
um
what about ryan and jeff what what uh
some of these things have impressed you
some of the uh i think i will share my
uh past experience uh like what joy has
mentioned
the moment when we get a resume even
from interns or somebody else
the first thing we look out for is the
alignment
the alignment of wordings and stuff
because as a designer these are the
things that
we are quite particular or quite quite
irritated by so so if
if the the first the first thing that
they submit to you
or the email to you uh they don't have
the eye for that i think
you know that they might not be you know
quite stable so
so i think that that would be the one
key thing that i'll
when we are looking at these other
things i will look for
uh some of it is i think the energy
level and of course through some
interviews
uh through some questions you can have a
feel
whether this person um if there are new
jobs or new things that changes whether
it's able to you know change accordingly
or adapt accordingly because now
you know it's it's covered or even in
the past uh
you although your jd is like that uh it
might not
be exactly the same when
you onboard because things change like
but of course the
the whole elements and stuff is still
the same but uh it might change
uh so so these are the questions that we
were asked like to see whether
this person if there's a change or shift
or some of
some some stuff in terms of roles
response responsibilities or even
stakeholder management which a lot of
designers
don't really feel comfortable to do that
so so these are the things that we will
i think is critical because uh as a
designer now if you
evolve it's not just probably doing
doing your work you still need to also
manage the stakeholders or people you
are also working on to
kind to kind of uh get them to buy in
your ideas like
correct okay so um
taking care of the little things like um
the alignment
right being able to adapt and and i
think what i'm picking up ryan is that
you you might throw over
some scenarios for to to just try and
see how they show
how how they might attend to that yeah
so i think that in the past is correct
in the past
and also i think a reminder around um
the fact that the role has now got
a lot more interaction with stakeholders
in it as well
so the ability to stick more to manage
too great careful about yourself jeff
so the question was uh what kind of
what uh what is uh has impressed you uh
about one team uh those who have wanted
to join my team
yes so maybe maybe the easiest way to
look at is
the the cvs that comes through these
days because we are also connected
i get cvs from linkedin to ig to
facebook to
emails it's it's it's it's really like a
daily business just to clear them
because um we it's a fierce competition
because i think
as we are connected to the world um a
lot of people
are using this opportunity to work
remotely because they don't even have to
come here
so we get cvs really from all over the
world
um i perhaps i start with what
what are the things that i don't like
right so i don't like cut and paste
cv so there are many times from linkedin
right you can see that people are
cutting and pasting cv
and the worst thing is they get my name
wrongly they get the agency wrongly and
then they try to believe the ending
ascent again
so that one no excuse straightaway will
go to the trash bin
but but the most um i i guess the the
most
impressive uh cv that i received right
uh is actually from um
people who actually go all the way to
the to you know take the extra
step to fabricate something i wish i had
that piece of
product uh with me uh like i shared with
you guys the other day so
uh there was a a staff who put together
um a craft piece of work and she molded
like a
chaju bao with uh with a usb stick
inside and then inside is all her work
i thought it was quite refreshing so
deliberately sent during lunchtime and
and you know
hey let's have lunch and you know all
that so it's all nicely
orchestrated so i thought something like
that was was it really
jumped out uh from uh from the rest and
definitely
she was hired but beyond that i think
that looking beyond
the the the song and dance but we do
look at the quality of work that comes
through
um i think for me uh it's it's um
when when someone presents themselves to
me uh i
i like to know what that person has done
in the last three months
uh because we want people who are very
current we want people who have the
pulse on
the industry and who who's actually done
work
that is actually um uh help drive
results
for the client whether it's it's a piece
of design work
whether it's a piece of exhibition
whether it's a piece of newsletter or a
piece of
television commercial we look at what's
what's what the person has done yeah so
for me that's uh recency
is is key
so the recently the the currency and and
um
the openness to just being aware of
what's going on
yeah um so i
i think i'm observing that there's a
whole bunch of questions that are
showing up so i'm wondering whether we
should
we should uh kind of like pop over and
take a look because i think some of
these questions are
responding to what you've been sharing
you know um given that our
our viewers a lot of them may uh be
graduating or uh just graduated
i think one of the concerns for those
who are just coming into the workforce
would be
around their chances at uh being
employable
especially when uh there's a need for
experience
so what advice would you give them in
that regard to improve their chances
i think um this is i think i'm taking
off from
from celine i think says what's your
take in getting juniors on board
and chipping into higher journeys and
fresh grants when the majority of the
companies seem to be more focused on
getting more
mid or senior levels so
what is your perspective on the
opportunities available
okay i think for for hiring perspective
right we try to
actually sometimes hiring managers so
have a tough spot because
we have some demand and supply right
sometimes the project comes in we have
certain time we say okay we need to
someone to hit and run which mean
hiring no time to train just jump on
board and just make it work
so that's why a lot of uh company tend
to hire
those uh kind of people with five year
plus experience that they can
they know what to do then they can jump
and do it the hiring manager itself need
to actually what
they need to do actually planning for
the future i mean they have to work
closely with hr
and luckily the singapore very very
helpful
and they try to actually groom the local
thailand right so you don't have that
much problem in singapore in other
countries you might have it but
the hiring manager the team lead not
only need to say okay the quota we
should have a balancing of
the new uh graph coming in dbs we have
singapore united program we're hiring
some one that's really fresh grab to
coming in we train them and they work
with us for another
year so those are the programs that each
design lead have to work
with the um the hr work with the design
single counsel sometimes work with other
organizations to actually make it work
but we all want to groom the local
thailand i mean i mean jeff and and
right now so we feel that
we need to groom someone in singapore
even in malaysia or thailand at least we
don't have to import people from
you know other uh geographic like
sometime i guess someone from europe us
but those are part of the diversity so
we try to keep the team quite balanced
i mean i have um 50 50 boys and girls
we have young from 20 plus to 40 plus so
actually
that helping to bring the team and build
a culture and i'm sure that
if you are don't afraid of you because
you are young or you just
graduate you just need to show potential
we hire for potential and actually
what you have already done actually we
need to say that okay what you can do in
the
in the future and then we give
opportunity to those
uh those talent great thank you
that's very that's a nice and hopeful um
thought there around looking not at what
you have but
your potential the future yeah
i think just to add on to what truex
said um the attitude is
is very important as well we have a
uh ihl program uh where we run in tomasi
polytechnic and nanyang polytechnic
called equator
so right now it's it's stopped for a
while because of kobe
we hope to resume um those programs very
soon
um so what we do is through that program
we actually bring in different faculties
a student
we hot house them uh and we train them
it's like internship but yet they
they get access to do the work that we
do both uh
locally and regionally um and which is
last week that i
i um i didn't even know that uh she she
actually came through as one of the
permanent hire
so there was this uh young young staff
who was from the equator program she she
decided to stay on with us and then we
actually gave her
her first promotion because of the
fantastic work that she has done
so i i want to encourage all the
fresh grads if you are
eager to to have a break in the design
industry
go in even as an apprentice as an as an
intern
your eagerness and your attitude will
show and i'm sure
between ryan and julie and and ourselves
we can spot a talent from a mile through
the way you interact and through the way
you it's it's that it's that x factor
we're looking for because
the skills you know you can you can take
your weekend to go and groom and
and learn and train but with the drive
and the attitude um you'll be sure that
you you'll be on a path
into this industry you can make a break
there
great fantastic thank you jeff ryan
there's a specific question that showed
up for you
so i'm just going to ask that oh yeah i
said
could ryan also share a bit more on your
journey
to switch across the diverse sectors
from your previous jobs
what might be the essential skills right
whether it's design or non-design that
enable a designer to survive
in diverse domain areas okay so
uh hello anonymous but anyway i think
it's like
that's right so a number so uh
when i was a lot of people like asking
me uh
or define my experience our industry
very interesting because finance and
wildlife
or animals are different or even versus
healthcare
and finance so i think
the core of doing or switching was
because
as an industrial designer back then as
we know the manufacturer
manufacturing uh uh all moving out back
maybe to china or hong kong and
stuff like that so the opportunities
might not be there so
what i've seen or i
at the time was uh i understand that
there was a trend of design thinking
uh that is up and coming like of course
user experience and so forth
or even like consultant role in that so
that was the
step where i decided to apply because
everybody knows that design thinking is
you know is how designer used to apply
to solve problems
so it's just the same context but you
just apply in a different industry
which is possible for example healthcare
patient experience
is the same as you know at a brunch a
customer walk walking in the branch
what are the needs and ones of course
the empathy so and so forth
and even back to you know the wildlife
the gas coming in or even the animals
you know that kind of thing so so these
are the things that
it's possible it's just that whether you
personally want to want to shift and of
course i think
earlier i mentioned about the hybrid of
piano the reason why you know from singh
health i joined dbs was
i understand that i was as a designer i
lack the business sense of stuff so
whenever i was trying to convince the
management it's a bit difficult because
when they ask me about all those
business stuff
i can't really understand so uh i know
in dbs i'm able to learn
uh because in dbs i'm like a consultant
like in a sense
internal consultant uh not really a
designer by an internal consultant
to do that so i know i'm able to learn
from it and subsequently if i leave
which i've left dbs i can apply all this
knowledge
into the next job with design with the
business which i think is very important
now
for me personally uh and even a fun fact
uh when i was at singh health moving
towards dbs
you know designers we don't like uh as
in designers our math
and science are quite bad in general uh
so so
from for a designer who who failed or
maybe
barely passed the math to go to the
finance it was a big
uh it was a leap of faith la i even i'm
a free thinker but i even went to the
gwaning temple to pray and ask for
advice but in the end i decided to move
this step because i think
it can the things i'm learning there it
can help me
move even further uh then of course
uh as things move right i think as a
designer you need to understand what
would be the next trend
and try to learn and try to uh be
well prepared so that you will not be
you know uh
not relevant to to to the next wave
yeah so i think design singapore has
quite a number of initiative and
you know classes and stuff like that
that you you all can yeah go and take a
look
helping the design singapore to sell
gold
thanks i think i think they have done a
good job yeah
thank you i i think you're also alluding
to that sense of currency
um maybe i can just uh check in here
with the three of you gentlemen um what
are some ways that
someone can stay current are there
places they should go things they should
read up where
you know where where do you go to stay
current in
in this sector what do you do
so actually we we subscribe but lots of
things for our team
we have a design library we actually buy
a lot of book and magazine
compose mostly not current but they give
you some guidelines something you can
flip it through
the magazine is the one actually give
you the current because they only have
issue with monthly so you learn lots of
things
from that we use senior as a e-magazine
so we subscribe but lots of magazine
like
even economists harvard reset review we
look at wire we look at fast company
we read a lot of we see block like first
round
we see we read a lot from that even
anderson we also read a lot from
we see world because that's that's how
far they can go with the
you know like the trend and everything
and we also
read quite a lot from news around the
world we are actually have actually i
mean
nothing very easy you just download
certain plugins right you can actually
get a lot of
news like designer news we have we have
blogging so
also when you read a lot but now the
problem that we have we have
too much information i think jeff and
ravia know we have so many things to
read
sometime like you only read when you
commute to work or
maybe you on the you know like camille
you read so you become podcast
so you listen to podcasts a lot then
you're multitasking
read the email i think we all do that
right but you need to
be specific on choosing the information
now i think that's what the heart is
and who who do you trust that
information coming from
because a lot of time you you listen to
something that
you know just waste your time if your
time is very precious now
and distraction from social media and a
lot of thing it
it's very hard to for young youngsters
actually to actually learn something new
that's what i found out
i mean we have lots of book in library
then no one checked out you know like it
just sit there
and we look into the record no one
actually read it and say why they don't
say oh they don't
carry thing back home sometimes they
don't have time to read
and they don't like to read so become we
actually subscribe to master class i
know you guys seen that app master class
it enough that one have the most uses
you know like people actually like the
short master class go and learn things
with video so we need to adapt on how we
learn thing as well but
yeah you have to be current you mean to
you have to know iphone coming up with
the thing you need to
you know actually be a beta user so you
know what's happening
yeah wow great
so yeah lots of different magazines so
you've recommended i love masterclass by
the way
oh yeah yeah um what about ryan and jeff
what what are some ways to stay current
where do you go
i just watch netflix okay
no no i mean i mean okay netflix is
important because
we do a lot of film uh and somehow they
had a kind of a good selection and
curation of
the the things coming up from
independent directors
uh and and to appreciate the film i mean
the way i watch a film i
i i can't i don't have enough time to
watch through everything so
i'll just like forward forward forward
forward right but i'm i'm that kind
like because i'm design trained i'll
watch the title sequence the opening the
typography
and and and all that so i get a kick
from watching those because i think it's
beautifully crafted
music videos are key as well to learn
from
and i can't agree more with what trevik
said about reading
i have a huge library of books when i
when i need to learn something that i do
not have knowledge of immediately it's
either you go to a library or a
kinopuniya to just pick up a book
you just flip through you you find that
literature
itself does give you a lot of ideas um
and actually it over um um circuit
breaker
like all the big universities like the
harvard
uh and mit they started to give out like
three lectures some of them you can just
buy for
20 30 and all that um so
i've attended because i'm i don't want
to spend so much money now so i attended
most of the free ones
and i find it very enlightening uh and
of course some of them could be quite
boring but to actually sit through
what a harvard professor could actually
be teaching you
online i thought that was
quite quite quite a nice and refreshing
way of absorbing new knowledge
and then you take that knowledge and you
see how you can apply it onto your work
so so uh curation it's very important
agree with juric there's
too many information uh you need to be
very judicious on what you choose
uh but maybe one advice is don't keep
looking at the things you already know
yeah look at um look at um adjacent uh
knowledge um so so if if you are
a ui ux designer perhaps look into
storytelling
because then you can bring storytelling
into you know how you
plan and and curate the user journey for
that person
um yeah because i think when you go a
json
um you then pick up something something
more and then
it add textures to your work
great so so some of the lectures that
you attended had nothing to do with
design i'm guessing
oh no no no no okay i once attended one
on quarks
you know um and i absolutely could not
understand it at all
so that was that was tough yeah thanks
jeff
uh ryan anything to uh okay so
personally i don't like to read it so so
what i do to
supplement all this is that i subscribe
to i do have flipboard
i like short articles and and also
uh like medium blogs and stuff like that
of course masterclass i think sherry has
mentioned i
really love it so uh let me tie in to
what jeff and troy has mentioned uh
jeff mentioned about uh james uh so
don't
don't read the things that you already
know so for example the things that i
like in master class
is one of it is called chris boss who
teaches the art of
negotiation negotiation so as a designer
or as a researcher uh you need to
interview people you need to
uh you know ask the correct question uh
to get
the thing that you want to find out so
you know all this thing it might not
if you read the normal thing it will be
the same thing but if you try to tie in
like the art of negotiation
into this then it will be something i
think
it might blow me in a way like on how to
ask in a certain way to get
some feedback or you know answers so
that is very very good
the other one is you know anna wintour
although it's a bit like you know devil
uh product uh the show itself so but but
i think that the
way that she talks about design uh how
she
should talk about the energy behind the
energy behind all this
i think you can learn from it although
it's not related to you know
directly to ux or you know user
interface or even design industrial
design and stuff like that
but the the whole mindset or the whole
energy behind all this you can learn
and actually apply in all this which
which you can
so so that's why to my job career it
doesn't need to be an industrial
designer out of the way love so it can
be
other things by just applying the same
context and what you have learned
previously
and apply next law correct that's my
thought
great thanks ryan yeah um i love chris
boss
yeah very very good especially
especially to your spouse maybe to check
whether they're lying or not
but yeah but it's it's a it's a good
it's a good
uh master class yeah
okay that's a plug for master class
right there um
okay a question may be around um
for our viewers who are mid-career are
there opportunities for matured workers
that are looking to come in from other
industries
from non-design backgrounds you know uh
what advice would you
could you be giving them okay so
you mean like never do decide work and
then like to change the fields right
so actually yes we have quite a few you
know we haven't won architect
uh actually he working as a professional
in architect he have
certificated everything then he moved
especially he went to study from uk
then he went back to china to be
architect but
he opened a studio but every time he
wanted to get the project he got under
table
so you know someone would just pitch the
project and get the project
in for him the next day so he started to
learn the new thing and you know using
the architect uh
background he actually learned a lot of
tools like sketch figma
and he actually managed to be a ux ui
designer today and he's actually one of
the leading designer in our team
so i think for for we would actually
jump off you know from
the current job right you need to know
what are the function or the skill that
you have in the job that you can
apply to the this uh design field
and you just learn whatever missing or
the gap that you have sometimes
maybe the same desired principle like
architect
and designer or user is actually quite
close
it's not that far away just the medium a
bit different they understand
space they understand people who
actually leap into the space
and the function so i think it actually
worked quite well
so don't don't don't feel kind of
discouraged that hey
it's very hard to jump in actually it's
not that hard but you need to
you need to maybe work harder than other
because
people that in the road already they
know what to do right so you have to
spend a bit extra effort to do that but
i i believe that
if someone really pursues something that
they want they will get what they want
so don't
you know just don't keep it just keep
doing it and then you will get there
super encouraging thank you i think i
wanted to share
i want to share two cases real life case
uh
that i've seen and very inspiring uh
back then when i was in dbs uh we are
uh um under this group transformation
group um so
there was this lady uh she was uh
studying marketing about she's doing all
partnerships and stuff like
back then so she she saw what we we have
done and did
so she in the end she left dbs and she
grew and
uh she went to ga to study uh ux courses
because she's so inspired to be a ux
designer
so i think it's possible and after that
now she's working at one of the
consultant
uh consultancy as a ux designer which i
was oh
okay that was great the other one is
because uh back then also in dbs
i was looking at uh regional meaning i'm
looking at china
and taiwan market uh so there was this
also lady in taiwan uh in taiwan dbs
uh she suddenly she told me that she's
going to she's leaving dbs i say why i
said then she said she's
she she is not her background is a
business but she went to study
ux ui uh courses during her weekend
like maybe once two days course for
maybe for six months
and after that she left dbs to join a
tech company
to become a ux designer which was very
inspiring for me and of course
the her boss was like saying oh because
all your fault
because we are doing very interesting
stuff so because all i thought that she
wants to change uh her industry
or her her career to become a ux
designer which is good for me
so i think i think it's possible it's
just that whether
it's all about you know back to your
mindset like it's possible
uh not saying that you don't have any
design or background or education you
can't do that
you still can do it because design
singapore back you know design singapore
even out there there are a lot of
courses
that you can learn about all this and
it's just that
you know whether you want to do it or
not of course
the starting point will be difficult and
that is the hard truth
because you are doing from stretch again
so you have to
change your mindset that after you study
you you know whether the salary or or
or or the journey will be tough uh you
have to be
brave enough or to to be to be believed
that
enough to to do it then i think it's
possible
yeah that's great thanks ryan i think
really nothing is lost then
everything that we have required nothing
is lost i actually have a specific
question to jeff
and truak from uh uh viewer
would you organizations hire or take an
intern residing in another country now
post cover
given that working remotely or hybrid is
going to be the norm
basically is there potential for design
teams that are spreading across
countries
going forward in the new normal is that
workable
so i think essentially it's about being
able to hire or take on someone who is
actually residing in another country
yeah that's the question this is to jeff
and shui
i think we have done that during circuit
breaker
when we were in the process of uh
high i mean we firm up the higher
highest already and they're in the
process of coming in
to singapore so then because of the
restriction
to to stay home notice and all that
right
it it costs um quite quite a little bit
of um
disruption to the travel and
accommodation and all that
uh so as a result of that um the people
that we've already hired were working
from their
original place of residence um and i
think it's something that's quite common
for us
um but if the question is talking about
in specific
with with specific to intern deciding
right um
i i maybe for intern the
the probability may be slightly lower
but if that person
is a uh has a special skill uh an
animator a designer that
we we are working with like for example
right now we're doing a film
uh we're working with um the production
unit from japan
right so it is uh an overseas
um kind of collaboration uh those we we
do
day to day um but uh in the same breath
so what happened is one of my colleagues
has actually joined our london office
uh but because of you know again this
situation
she has to be here for a couple of
months
uh and she basically had to switch her
time to
the european time so that she can be um
working at their at their ideal
schedule so um i think it's it's it's
becoming a reality
uh right now um i i guess the the
the next step is once you are an
established
designer offering a kind of service that
is unique uh to what the businesses are
looking for
then the questions come to you is can
you work 247
around the globe okay
yeah it's the uniqueness is what what
you have to offer
hey jeff right uh how about you eight
any thoughts so i think
in turn in the past right we normally
doing
uh offer for people actually locally in
singapore
we never done the intern like you know
like remotely yet but
it might coming up eventually because
i think the the work from home policy
have been changed i mean
you know when we work in the us both
from home is very normal
i mean normally friday we work from home
to avoid traffic and everything and then
we can have more time to do other thing
but in singapore last time they don't
allow
because maybe the trust is not there and
then the norm is not there so
the employers say okay i don't know that
you what you do on friday you don't
working but it might changing
remote working is is it might be us a
bit more serious now i think they might
think about okay
why don't we hire someone remotely and
then they can work uh
full-time remodeling i think the company
in the u.s have done that in the past
uh the word from rework the json file
who actually
found a 37 signal the base cam
application actually the whole company
actually remote
worker so actually it's impossible and
then i can
feel that in the future they may have
someone a world two job you know
like three day i work for ddb today i
may work for
ryan because i like the sue i want to
work
isn't that possible actually because you
don't need to commute so much
so that that might happen in the future
so we just need to be ready and then
for intern i think what you need to you
try to look out for what company you
want to work for
and the important thing when i i see god
for intern when i
am younger right actually i look on who
actually designing that company
who actually the principle of the design
in that studio
at least you learn something good you
have very short time mostly in term
three months right
so that time is the best time for you
actually learn from that person that
actually they have done
a lot of something in the past so you
can you know pick it up and you can be a
better designer faster
yeah great thank you so much um
okay so i have two more questions that
are showing up thank you
everyone for uh sending along your
questions
he's making for a very interesting
discussion so
this is a reverse question with remote
work giving rise
to possibilities of hiring someone from
far away lands
do you think inspiring singaporean
designers should also look to tap into
opportunities to work remotely
for an overseas company so
yeah any thoughts totally
totally i i think the world the world
has
already opened up i mean even before
kobet but just
because kobit has uh kind of given us a
proof point that work
um away from the actual office is
actually possible
um i say go for if if you can lend
yourself
and freelance work um go work at
different places to
to kind of just level up yourself and
work with different creative directors
and then
just build up your experience from there
um i think
we are looking at a generation of um
people who who want to work with
different experiences live experiences
in the past you know we love to travel
and and work
just because you can absorb the culture
and all that so it's
while that is lacking but it's also
allow us to you know in the comfort of
our home you know work for australia
today tomorrow for uk and then go to
india
you know if if such assignment happened
i i think
um it's it's actually quite challenging
because then you get to interact with
different culture
and you know how to then present
yourself and present your idea and to
negotiate
uh with with this different culture i
think this is a
steep learning curve but it's worth
worth a shot
don't do it for the money though do it
for the experience
good yeah and i mean what what a great
way to
kind of get all the experiences sitting
exactly in your bedroom
and yeah be you know some parts in
australia and some parts in
you know whichever parts of the world it
is so this is good um
what about uh chewie ryan any thoughts
on
on this uh
i think i think you should do it i mean
if
if you have a chance right working in
with a different country actually give
you
a perspective i mean you can in
singapore you can speak mandarin you
should try to work for
maybe china company like those tencent
you know alibaba or whatever they're
coming up because that
actually you have an ish you understand
mandarin so it's actually helping you to
kind of learn in those environment and
you know what other design
theme and coming up there actually
helping you uh to grow as a
as a designer or anything that you do
today
thank you chewie i think we probably
have time for one last question so i
i suspect this one i'm not sure if it's
from an ihl but to the panel
if there can be an employer's wish list
what are the things that you wish
academic institutions can prepare their
graduates for
something that's currently missing from
the interviews that you
receive okay so i think if
they want to prepare i think one is i
think as jeff say that
you know we we actually decide for
passion but we work for money right
so the other thing that they need to
plan actually for granted like
help them to understand financial 101
also because
it it's just really hard to be a
designer when
when sometimes the asian family do not
support
a kid to be a designer they like they
like the kid to be a doctor
be a banker engineer and lots of things
right you actually pass that stage
now you're on the real world right i see
if the
company or maybe the um these are guys
actually host the finance 101 to helping
them understand
what is salary ban benchmark is about if
what is the right ban to be
in um those are the things actually
helpful because a lot of time i saw some
i mean i i hired a lot of in the last
seven years
some people are coming from certain
company they're banned very low i don't
know how they survive i mean
it's too low and it took us some time
three four years to adjust them to be at
the par you know
and working with hr because sometimes i
say oh you cannot increase people more
than 15 percent
i say yes but is it too low you cannot
so a lot of things that
if if um i mean organization like um
this has you can helping that
actually we're helping to grow the kind
of
talent in locally in singapore as well
because
i think it's a important aspect
okay great it's having it's having that
awareness with the finance
um the 101 that's great um what about
ryan
and uh jeff uh i think i can add on
uh because i taught before uh in
polytechnics and i think
one missing stuff that uh in education
people as in preparing students uh to
to to the workforce is that i think two
things that might be lacking
and i think can be done in a sense that
or even
personally you can go and try to do it
i'll try to learn is that
uh first thing is more about you know
how to stick hold uh stakeholder
management because as if you are as a
designer
okay in in schools we learn about what
is the design process
uh what are the correct ways methods to
to come up with ideas
prototype and stuff like that so that is
the user but
they really never teach about what about
stakeholder management because
as a designer i think one key role is
that we
are the breach in terms of the customer
and of course to the stakeholders and of
course to the developers and
and so on and so forth is the linkage of
everybody
so so i think that is uh very important
uh
to to me like or even as a young
designer should have the other one i
think
it's uh the the mindset to to say that
it's okay to fail because um
in schools it's always saying that okay
we need to
do uh do it in the sense that we have to
do it correctly
okay so so but but in the real world
uh things doesn't follow or go as
as planned and you might get some
setback same thing as design thinking
we have to do the uh ideation prototype
and you know you have to film a number
of times so is that part that
i think uh i think uh as a young
designer or even as a student you
need to be aware of it's okay to fail or
or
to have some setback but you know how do
you learn from that
and try to be better like in a sense
yeah so two things thank you ryan
stakeholder management and um
have it be okay to fail right jeff i'm
gonna give you the last word on this
i think then we have to wrap it up
much much to add i think the two
gentlemen have kind of like covered it
quite well so but maybe just one tip
uh for graduates uh graduates are
applying for a job right is maybe
perhaps
do your homework before you you meet the
person
look up uh what the person has done uh
what
what is what is the what does the
company stand for
and perhaps a little bit i mean this is
the soft skills that you you can have in
and having a conversation having a
meaningful conversation
and perhaps try to even spa with the
with your future boss and talk about
because in the
in the process of creative ideation it's
all about exchange
right because when you you allow
yourself to be vulnerable and then you
build ideas upon
other people's idea and that's how the
the work goes
um maybe talk about the work and have
your opinion be bold to
to share what you think of the work um
of course i mean if you are very verbal
you can say that i
really don't like the piece of work that
you put up recently i thought it could
have been better
it's okay right but you put it to share
you have
some good grounding now right but don't
go to the over overboard and say i
i really like the work that you do no
like it doesn't work that way as well
i think be honest once you have once
you're honest and often
and authentic in the conversation um i
think
that that people skills is is actually
um
very important because um as you may
have heard
uh from the three of us uh stakeholder
holder management that ryan
uh um uh emphasized on and how you
present
your your idea across the culture uh
it's actually
best exhibited best presented through a
person and
it's still a very people-to-people uh
kind of thing so i i think
the interpersonal skills is very
important thank you jeff
so i think interpersonal skills and come
prepared basically so that you can there
to have an opinion
hopefully the person you're giving
opinion to will be secure enough to take
it
all right thank you thank you so much uh
jeff ryan and truay
um i think it's been the most
enlightening time i've learned a lot
taking a lot of notes as well
so i appreciate that very much um and i
think we'll hand this time over
to uh normal right
okay awesome okay so i know that i only
have um
seven or eight minutes to finish this
and i have quite a bit to share
so i will go through quite quickly and
if you have any questions you can
actually feel free to type in the chat
and my colleague ky can help to answer
and if i end on time i will also try my
best to answer whatever questions that
you guys have
okay so um there are to be a few things
that i'm going to share today
but i'm going to um highlight two very
important things that i'm going to
to share and the first would be work
study programs okay
so essentially there are numerous work
study programs that fall under
skills features singapore so what are
some of the benefits of this
program is essentially you get career
progression and articulation
and you have the opportunity to work in
a company so essentially how it works is
that you work and study at the same time
so uh so approximately maybe about one
to two
days the week you go to school and the
other days you go
for work at a company that you are that
you are attached to
essentially and you also get a sign up
incentive of up to five thousand dollars
okay so let me just share with you what
are the various programs
uh but before that i just want to share
with you that there are a number of
people who who have gone through the
program
and have said that they have benefited
very much from the programs
and a lot of them have said that they
also uh make more than their peers
okay and just for for the rest of you
who if you guys have heard of this state
of this term
before and
program it's
actually the same thing so it's
rebranded as a work study program it
used to be called
the independent program okay so this uh
this is the overview of programs if you
look at this particular
bowl for uh skill social work study
program work study diploma and modulus
sets which
will lead to part-time diploma okay
and you will also be eligible for the
boot camp skills future work study
certificate a boot camp so for poly
graduates
you will be eligible for the work study
post diploma
and work study degree and a level
graduates
you will be eligible for the work study
degree okay
and all of them like what i mentioned
ite grads polygraphs and
a level grads all of them will be uh
will be eligible for the
work study certificate boot camp so this
boot camp is
boot camp is about six to eight weeks
left okay it's like intensive uh
in intensive boot camp where you learn
as much as you can in this you know six
to eight weeks
okay so there's about 134 work study
programs of more than 1 000
participating companies across
35 different sectors
all right so if you need more
information on the work study program
you can actually go online
okay you can actually go online on the
skillshare website and find out even
more about it
all right so that is the first important
thing that i want to share with you
and the second important thing that i
want to
share with you is this portal already
used it before
but for those of you who have not okay
essentially it is a
it's a one-stop portal where you do
everything related to
your skills future needs so for example
you want to search for a course you go
to this portal you want to sign up for a
course you go to this portal
you want to check how much skills future
credit you have left
you can go to this portal as well okay
so
you can also download the app but i
would uh i would advise you best to
use your computer or your laptop like to
just access the website
okay all right so if you want to
look at the work study programs in the
portal as well
okay uh hold on let me just
okay so if you want to assess the
programs in the portal as well
give me a minute
okay so you can go to the my skills
future portal go under digital services
and look for apply for skills future
work study
program okay and you can take a look at
the different programs that fall under
the work and work study programs are
essentially
okay
uh all right so for example for me right
what i do is that i go to the i go to
the website
and i type design okay and i can
actually take a look
at the different programs under design
sector
in the work and study program in that
particular website itself
right so also in the website what are
some of the things that were some other
things that you can do in the website
like what i mentioned
you can actually search for courses okay
you can search for courses in the
website
but if you want to check out your skills
future credit balance and things like
that you have to log in with your
sync pass okay and other things that you
can do also
is you can actually do self-assessment
tests for example you want to find out a
bit more about yourself like
oh am i a more social person or am i
more artistic person or things like that
you can actually take certain tests in
this particular website
and they will tell you the results and
they will also tell you okay
you know what you are a social person so
what sort of jobs
suit you better okay and you can also
build up your skills passport meaning
all the causes that you have take taken
using your skills with your credit
or not as well you can actually it will
actually be inside the skills passport
okay so i barely have a few minutes left
i'll just try my best to share the rest
here
so for those of you who require more
support and resources with regards to
your career
advice and career career development
okay you can actually arrange a session
with skills ambassadors
okay skills and training advisory
services all right you can go to the
link at the bottom
or you can also attend skills future
advice webinars
okay so skill social advice webinar is
is going to be a more lengthy sharing
on skills features support and resources
and during that particular webinar we
will also do
a profiling test like what i mentioned
earlier okay we will also do a profiling
test
like what i mentioned earlier so you can
actually go to the link and sign
up for any one of the webinars so the
skills which are advised webinar ranges
from about one hour or so
all right can i so on top of that we
also have career centers in singapore
where you can actually see a
career coach for free and there are five
career centers
three of them falls under work for
singapore and two of them falls under
e2i
which is employment and employability
institute so i never got a chance to
introduce where i came from as well
so myself i am actually from e2i
employment and employability institute
so what you have to do is that you just
have to call the number or go to the
website and make an appointment
so when you see a career coach it's free
however do remember to bring your resume
and things like that so that the
curriculum will be able to help you
further
okay and also some uh sg united
traineeships i'm not sure if you guys
have heard of this before
ng united traineeships are available for
fresh
graduates and also graduating students
okay
where you will you will go through a
traineeship like over a period of
quite a long time like a few months or
so so what you can do is that you can
scan the qr code to find out a little
bit more
or if you have any specific questions
about this you can feel free to type in
the chat and i will see if i can address
them
okay all right that's all that i'm going
to be sharing today
thanks for sharing thank you very much
nuru for sharing
the resources and thank you praise jeff
chuak and ryan for your insights and
advice
on the importance of early career
planning and continuous professional
improvement so we've come to the end of
our session and we hope that you have
been inspired by it
if you'd like to find out more about dsg
scholarship and skills future study
award for design scheme
do scan the respective qr codes on your
screen now
the links to both resources can be found
in the zoom chat now too
we would also appreciate if you could
take some time to share your feedback on
the session
through a quick survey by scanning the
qr code on the left
the link to the survey can also be found
in our zoom chat
and lastly if you'd like to find out
more about the programs at the national
design center in october
scan the qr code that you see on the
right
thank you once again for spending your
tuesday evening with us
we hope that to see you in a future
event soon and stay well take care
and goodbye
you